قبل أكثر من 40 سنة
عُرض ولأول مرة مسلسل «عدنان ولينا»
كانوا كتّاب المسلسل يتخيلون المستقبل
بأسلحة ضوئية ومغناطيسية
وسيارات وقوارب طائرة
بس
وصلنا 2008 ولا شفنا التقنيات هذه
لكن اللي صار شيء ثوري أكثر
شيء ما قدروا يتخيلونه
لا في «عدنان ولينا»
ولا باقي أفلام الخيال العلمي
تقنية بتغير طريقة عيش البشرية
هذه التقنية
المفترض تخلينا نعيش في عالم مثالي
وما أبالغ لما نقول مثالي
عالم كلنا أجسامنا فيه صحية ورياضية
بدون حتى ما نروح النادي
بدون حتى ما تجاهد نفسك
على قطع الأكل اللي تحبه
عالم نقدر نختار فيه شكل عيالنا
كثافة شعارهم، لون عيونهم
عالم ما فيه أمراض وراثية
ولا إيدز وملاريا تنتقل بين البشر
ولا سرطان يقتل فوق 9 مليون إنسان
سنويًا حول العالم
مو بس كذا
من الممكن أن البشرية ما تشيخ أبدًا
السؤال، من 2008 إلى الحين
أيش اللي مانعنا من استخدام هذه التقنية؟
عشان نفهم أيش هالتقنية
خلونا نرجع للوراء عشرة آلاف سنة
لمّا الإنسان كان يعيش بشكل بدائي
الحضارات لم تتشكّل بعد
والعلوم جميعها في بدايتها
حتى وسائل العيش كانت بشكل بسيط وبدائي
مثل الزراعة وتربية الماشية
من هذاك الوقت والإنسان عارف
أن فيه صفات تنتقل
من الوالدين للأبناء بعد التزاوج
ومن الممكن أن الإنسان
يحدد هذه الصفات
إذا اختار الأب والأم بشكل صحيح
وعشان كذا
صاروا يختارون الخيل والفرس المناسب
عشان ينتجون خيول أجمل
أو أبقار تدرّ حليب أكثر
أو دجاج يعطيك بيض أكبر
ما كان الإنسان يعرف
ليش وكيف تنتقل هذه الصفات
ولكن
في القرن الماضي، عرف
والسبب هو الجينات
الجين هذا
هو تسلسل مكوّن من أربع حروف
الـ(A) و(G) و(C) و(T)
الجينات هذه هي اللي تحدد صفاتك
أنا محمد جالس اليوم
شكلي، لون شعري، عيوني
حتى احتمالية إصابتي بأمراض معينة
محددة بشكل كبير من الجينات
هذه الجينات
ثلاثة ونصف بليون حرف
يعني لو كاتب يشتغل
ثمانية ساعات في اليوم
بس مشغول يكتب هذه الحروف
بتأخذ منه أكثر من خمسين سنة
عشان يخلصها
لما عرفوا العلماء أن الجين
هو المسؤول الأول والأخير
عن كل هذه الأشياء
كان الهاجس عندهم دائمًا
هل نقدر نتحكم ونغيّر
بصفات المخلوقات الحية؟
أننا نعيد كتابة هذا الجين؟
من هذا المنطلق
بدأت التجارب
في عام 1982
جربنا التعديل الجيني على البكتيريا
وضبط!
وقدرنا ننتج الأنسولين
استخدام الأنسولين
كان يُنتج بتعديل جيني على البكتيريا
وبعدين يأخذوا الأنسولين هذا
ويحقنوه للبشر
هذا كان بداية علاج السكر
وجربنا التعديل الجيني على النباتات وضبط
البطاطس، الطماطم، الذرة
عُدلت جينيًا
حتى تقاوم المبيدات بشكل أفضل
وتتحمل درجات الحرارة المختلفة
وجربناه على الحيوان
وضبط!
كثير من سمك السلمون اليوم
مُعدل جينيًا عشان ينمو بشكل أسرع
وعلى الإنسان
هنا كانت المشكلة
كل تقنيات التعديل الجيني
المتوفرة وقتها
كانت خطيرة وغير دقيقة
للتجارب على البشر
كنا نعرف الجينات وترتيبها
بس ما نعرف كيف نغيّر فيها
بشكل آمن وعملي
ولكن، البكتيريا كانت تعرف
بين البكتيريا والفيروسات حرب دائمة
ومع الوقت
قدرت البكتيريا تطوّر نظام مناعة
يسجل أجزاء من جينات الفيروس
بحيث لما يجي من الفيروس مرة ثانية
تقدر البكتيريا تتعرف عليه
وتقص جيناته
وتقتله
بدون ما يتأثّر أي شيء آخر
هذه التقنية الدفاعية
اسمها «كرسبر»
في 2008
اكتشفنا أننا نقدر نختار
جين مسؤول عن مرض معين مثلاً
ونعطيه البكتيريا
وهي بنظامها الدفاعي كرسبر
تقص الجين بالكامل
ما يصير موجود في جسمك
ولا ينتقل لعيالك
زي الضمور العضلي مثلًا
طيب، نكمل؟
أنت تبدأ الحالة طفل طبيعي
وبعدين تبدأ تظهر الأعراض كل ما يكبر
يعني أنا لو أقدر أرفع يدي بس
هذا شيء عظيم
هذا واو، الجهاز رهيب! أنا مرة رهيب
يعني أحس فيه تغيير كبير
بالنسبة لمرضى الضمور
هي من الحالات المعدّلة جينيًا
اللي نجح فيها التعديل الجيني
كرسبر اليوم تصل دقة عمله 90%
وعشان نستوعب ضخامة هذه الدقة
نسبة النجاح هذه
أعلى من كثير من العمليات الجراحية
بكذا كرسبر حلّ المشكلتين
اللي كانت تواجه التعديل الجيني
صار دقيق ورخيص
يعني لو بيضبط كرسبر
مثل ما هو قادر عليه
يمكن تقفّل المستشفيات
ما حيكون فيه شيء اسمه
«مرض في المجتمع»
كرسبر كتقنية بحتة
قد تكون الحل المستقبلي
لكثير من مشكلات البشرية
ولكن
في عام 2018
فيه باحث صيني صدم العالم
لمّا أعلن في مؤتمر للتعديل الجيني
أنه عدّل ولأول مرة
على جينات أجنّة
في الأشهر الأولى من الحمل
لا يوجد شخص في علم الأخلاقيات
إلا وتحدّث تجريمًا لهذا الشخص
قالوا فيه إن فعله وحشي
غير مسؤول وشنيع
وعُوقب وسُجن في الصين
مع أن والد الجنين
كان يحمل جين لمرض الأيدز
وكان الهدف من التعديل
هو إزالة جين الأيدز
لكن ليش هالعقاب الشديد؟
وليش هو ممنوع أصلًا؟
التعديل الجيني على الخلايا الجسدية
مسموح جزئيًا تطبيقه على الإنسان
في كثير من دول العالم
ولكن ممنوع تمامًا
في أكثر من أربعين دولة
أنك تعدّل على الخلايا التناسلية
الخلايا اللي ينقلها الإنسان للـ(Pro-Gene)
أو للجيل الثاني
هي ما تسمى الخلايا الـ(Germline cells)
اللي هي «الخلايا التناسلية»
إذا عملت تعديل جيني وأخطأت
الخطأ هذا يكون مدمّر
لأن التعديل الجيني على الأجنّة
والبويضات والحيوانات المنوية
بيُنتج عنه تعديل دائم ومستمر ومتوارث
والسيطرة عليه بتكون أصعب
تذكر ال90% نسبة النجاح لكرسبر؟
هذه صحيحة
ولكن المشكلة كلها موجودة
في الـ10%
نسبة الفشل هذه الممكنة
يعني مثل لما تقول
10% من رحلات الطيران
بتطيح وتحترق
نسبة قليلة ولكن كارثية
وهو مدمر لأن الجينات متداخلة ومترابطة
ممكن الجين المسبب للسرطان
هو نفسه الجين الخاص بالنظر مثلًا
ولكن بالرغم من كل هالمشكلات والتحديات
إلا أن المصابين بأمراض
علاجها الوحيد هو كرسبر
مستعدين للمخاطرة
أنا ما أشوف أنه عندي مانع
أني أخذ علاج واعد
وقد يكون له مضاعفات مستقبلية
الآن يعيّشني الفترة هذه
بجودة حياة أعلى
أما السبب الثاني للمنع
هو صعوبة تحديد ما يُعالج بالتعديل الجيني
أنا أتوقع طبعًا إذا خلصنا من المشكلات اللي تدعم الحياة
رح يدخلوا على التجميل، هذا أكيد
كرسبر ممكن يسمح لك
باختيار الشكل اللي تريده لطفلك
أنا ممكن أغيّر شخصية الشخص
إذا غيرت الجينات
اللي لها علاقة بالشخصية
الجينات اللي لها علاقة بالذكاء
وهذا ما يُعرف بـ«تصميم الأطفال»
برضو ممكن تجي دولة تقول لك
أنا أبغى كل أبناء شعبي
عيونهم خضراء
وشعرهم أشقر
هتلر حاول يسويها
الإنسان المثالي
من وجهة النظر النازية في هذيك الفترة
هو الشخص المفتول القوي الطويل
أبو شعر أصفر وعيون زرق
فكانوا يجيبوا الأشخاص هذول
ويسووا لهم برامج تزاوج
مو زواج، تزاوج
مع سيدات يحملن نفس المواصفات
بحيث أنه يكون فيه جيل
مُهجّن بحيث أنه
يركز أنه أنا أبغى المجتمع
يكون بهذه الكيفية
نفس الفكرة اللي يُجرم فيها
الانتخاب العرق النازي
يُجرّم فيه الانتخاب الجيني
لأي أسباب أخرى
لا، أبغى والله ولدي يكون أسرع ولد
أقوى ولد، أطول ولد
أعظم ولد، أذكى ولد
نسبة ذكاء مرتفعة
هذه كلها تخلّي المجتمع في النهاية
يتمايز إلى تصوّرات قبلية
لـ«ما هي المثالية؟»
مين اللي يحط «ما هي المثالية؟»
هذا هو السؤال
ولو اتفقنا وشرّعت الأنظمة
التعديل الجيني للعلاج دون التجميل
أيش اللي يفرق بين
هل إزالة السمنة علاج؟
كثير من شركات التأمين
تعتبر التكميم جزء من التجميل
ولو سُمح للتعديل الجيني
بأن يكون متاح للجميع بأساليب بسيطة
هل بتُعتبر متلازمة داون مرض يجب علاجه؟
هل بتسمح للتعديل الجيني
أن يمحوا متلازمة داون من الوجود مثلًا؟
بالرغم من اللي فيهم داون وأهاليهم
ما يشوفوهم مرضى
أنا رجل بمتلازمة داون
وحياتي تستحقّ العيش
لذلك السبب بالتحديد
في الأخلاقيات حاجة اسمها (Slippery slope)
أو «المنزلق»
إذا سمحت للفكرة
لن تستطيع أن تسيطر عليها
يعني الانحراف ترى
يبدأ درجة واحدة
ثم يصبح كيلومترات بين النقطتين
اليوم تقنية كرسبر تعدّل على الجين
الجين اللي يُعتبر أصغر من حجم النملة
بأربعة مليون مرة
تقنية كرسبر تتطور
وبنستخدمها أكثر وأكثر
لحل مشكلات البشرية
ولكن الحذر في تعديل شيء أساسي وجوهري
الحمض النووي للإنسان
سلالاتنا البشرية
هذا الحذر هو اللي بيضمن لنا
أن نستخدم هذه التقنية
دون أن نقع في حفرة التعديل الجيني